grazie a tutte intanto è un piacere
essere qui finalmente a cesena
io sono matteo ceri sono un ricercatore
dell'università e di bologna e oggi vi
parlerò di ibernazione una cosa che sa
sempre un po di fantascienza e infatti
quando pensiamo alla prova l'ibernazione
e alla fantascienza ci viene da guardare
il cielo di dire chissà dove si potrebbe
andare e liberazione in effetti è uno
dei pilastri della fantascienza qualcuno
di voi riconoscerà in queste quattro
foto quattro famosi film che non
avrebbero potuto esistere se non si
fosse pensato alla nazione come trucco
cinematografico
in realtà oggi non è più così
fantascienza per esempio questo è un
articolo del guardian che ripropone
l'ipotesi si può effettivamente bernero
non possiamo veramente viaggiare nello
spazio ibernando le persone beh oggi la
cosa ha preso una piega un po più decisa
l'esa l'agenzia spaziale europea ogni
giorno mi ha telefonato il mio telefono
squilla invece buongiorno dottor ce li
siamo dell'esa ci interesserebbe
iniziare un gruppo di ricerca che lavori
su questo progetto in visione della
missione su marte e anche altre cosa
dice vengo volentieri
e infatti adesso faccio parte di un
gruppo di ricerca di consulenza per
l'esa che comprende molti colleghi di
tutto il mondo esattamente lavoriamo
cercare di sviluppare una tecnologia che
consenta di bernareggio astronauti in
realtà l'origine di questa tecnologia
era pensata per la sanità ma ne parliamo
un pochino dopo che nel dettaglio
intanto cos'è l'ibernazione una parola
che tutti conosciamo gergalmente come
letargo anche a volte quello che non
sappiamo in realtà è che l'ibernazione è
uno stato complesso che si divida in
tante categorie diverse esiste
l'estimazione l'ibernazione il torpore
per semplificare pensate che
l'ibernazione una condizione nella quale
la nostra con il nostro consumo di
energia si riduce fondamentalmente quasi
a zero
esistono animale che lo scoiattolo
artico la cui temperatura corporea
riesce a scendere addirittura sotto zero
meno due meno 3 gradi centigradi durante
la stagione dell'ibernazione lo so
questi sono grafici gli scienziati usano
grafici ce ne sono pochissime le
presentazioni di guiderò attraverso la
loro vettura ma questo serve solo a
farvi capire che questa capacità ha la
capacità di raffreddarci noi in realtà
ce la portiamo dietro da molto tempo
i nostri predecessori rettili che nella
scala evolutiva vengono proprio appena
prima di noi
in realtà infatti non sono in grado di
mantenere la loro temperatura corporea
costante per cui si raffreddano quando
l'ambiente freddo e si riscaldano quando
l'ambiente caldo
se avete mai visto una lucertola
d'estate quello che fa l'inizialmente
stesso una roccia aspettare che il sole
la skull di sé quando è caldo può
iniziare la sua vita la sua attività
noi invece siamo in grado di mantenere
la nostra temperatura corporea costante
e perché siamo in grado perché molto
tempo fa 150 milioni di anni fa forse un
po di più
il primo mammifero che compare sulla
terra al trovato mammifero si trova di
fronte a un problema non indifferente la
terra in quel periodo è popolata da
dinosauri e quindi non è facile andare a
prendere le ghiande mentre il t rex ci
passeggia sopra e quindi bisogna trovare
un modo come fare
beh una modo geniale sarebbe quello di
riuscire andare a fare la spesa fra
virgolette di notte quando non c'è il
sole perché dinosauri di notte sono più
fredde
perché non sono in grado di generare il
loro calore e noi invece si è una
strategia rischiosa generale il proprio
calore costa molta energia è un trade
off proprio appena appena bilanciato ma
funziona e quando i rosari finalmente si
estinguono i mammiferi iniziano a
popolare la terra a dominarla in tutte
le nicchie ecologiche e l'ibernazione
fra i molti di loro diventa superflua
non ci sono più predatori non è più
necessario questo tipo di risparmio
la mantengono però gli animali che si
trovano in ambiente molto sfavorevoli
questa la marmotta delle alpi per
esempio cosa fa la marmotta dalle alpi
quando i berna fa questo tipo di cosa
che poi diceva di un'altra figura una
lato grafico ci sono molti dati in
queste figurano figura storica
l'unica cosa che ritengo interessante
sia questa cosa grigia che a un certo
punto vedete cade vicino all'asse dello
zero cosa vuol dire quello è il consumo
energetico di quell'animale che
improvvisamente in grado di crollare la
marmotta autonomamente e in grado
attivamente di spegnere il suo motore ha
un minimo indispensabile per
sopravvivere
questo sarebbe molto utile medicina ci
consentirebbe per esempio di far
sopravvivere con minor danni le persone
che hanno un ictus cerebrale o un
arresto cardiaco il cervello
insomma tantissimo improvvisamente
potrebbe smettere di consumare e quindi
superare il periodo critico senza danni
oggi non si può fare
si usa un pochino di raffreddamento ma
si fa poco in maniera poco diversa da
questo col ghiaccio quando i fluidi
freddi e il nostro organismo non vuole
raffreddarsi tra l'altro che
raffreddarsi fosse una cosa positiva
l'avevamo capito molto tempo fa perché
dovete la campagna di russia per esempio
mi dice francesi avevano scoperto una
cosa interessante quando andavano ad
accogliere i feriti sul campo
portavano i medici gli ufficiali ancora
dire degli ufficiali soldati nel
quartiere dei soldati qual è la
differenza tra i due anche gli ufficiali
avevano un quartiere riscaldato si stava
bene perché erano ufficiale purtroppo
per loro gli ufficiali morivano come
mosche e i soldati che invece erano
acquartierati al freddo sopravvivevano
per cui l'idea era che raffredda si
potesse far bene in queste condizioni è
fra l'altro medici francesi giungono a
cambiare la definizione di morte sul
campo di battaglia domande che si fanno
è ma il corpo in decomposizione se in
decomposizione era la persona è morta
sennò quand'è che può essere morta
diciamo che se la sua testa lontana a
mezzo metro dal corpo allora la persona
è morta in tutte le altre condizioni
pensiamoci bene poi ci sono altri paesi
viene 12 questa la cittadina di scopi in
russia nella quale un anonimo scrittore
del british medical journal nel 1900
dice che la popolazione
cito letteralmente sleeps de winter of
cioè passa viale verona dormendo
riunendo sé una grande casa nel centro
del villaggio senza mangiare e
aspettando la primavera
nessuno ha mai confermato però queste fi
knicks poi ci sono esempi più recenti è
sicuramente molto più monitorati questa
la dottoressa anna bug o una collega un
medico anche lei norvegese che è
accaduto in un fiordo gelato facendo
cross country ski sci di fondo è rimasto
un'ora sott'acqua è stata ripescata una
temperatura corporea di 13,8 gradi
centigradi e stata rianimata e la
dottoressa anna sto benissimo e ha
raccontato la sua esperienza in alcuni
articoli molto rilevanti esiste quindi
un modo per sopravvivere a queste
condizioni
esiste un modo che viene da lontano
viene dal nostro albero genealogico
ancestrali e se vedete questi che sono
tutti i mammiferi che tutte le loro
classi
guardiamo questi punti colorati e sono
tutte le specie che sono in grado di
andare in ibernazione torpore e steve
azione o qualunque
capacità di sopprimere la loro spesa
energetica sono distribuite in tutto
l'arco
il che vuol dire che il nostro antenato
originale era in grado di fare questa
cosa è che anche noi ragionevolmente
saremo in grado di farlo
infatti questo per esempio è un paziente
che arrivò al dipartimento di neurologia
dell'università di bologna nel 2002 con
una strana sindrome lui è tanto si
sentiva stanco stanco stanco e non
riusciva a stare in piedi dove la
propria serie si perdeva conoscenza
tutti gli esami era negativi non si
sapeva cosa avesse fin quando un collega
molto astuto non registrò la sua
temperatura e scoprì che quest'uomo
andava in una condizione di torpore
l'ibernazione spontanea sono molto rari
stati riscritti anche altri casi però
nel mondo
quindi sicuramente si può fare e come si
può fare
e beh quando ci mettiamo al freddo se
ora foste uno di questi due modelli
avesse un freddo dell'anima e ovviamente
è il vostro corpo farebbe brivido
sarebbe molto piacevole aumenterebbe la
frequenza cardiaca la pressione e tutti
questi organi si attiverebbero per
mantenere la vostra temperatura corporea
costante quello che vogliamo fare noi e
quello che abbiamo fatto noi
per riuscire per la prima volta a
mandare in ibernazione un animale che
non li berna e spegnere questo controllo
spegnere il modo in cui il cervello
comanda questi organi dicendo questi
organi di non funzionare più
la regione del cervello che controlla
questione che ne è una regione molto
piccola di una parte ancestrale del
nostro cervello
questa porzione si chiama rafa è pallido
essendo tutti i nomi di aree cerebrali
latine di solito ed equa evidenziata
infiorescenza ma adesso questi sono
dettagli sulla scenografici
ma questo è il motore l'interruttore
l'accendino che fa scaldare il nostro
corpo come abbiamo bisogno di di farlo e
ci fa consumare energia spegnerlo ci fa
risparmiare infatti questo è un grosso
ratto ripreso con una telecamera ad
infrarossi i colori più sono accesi più
significa che sono caldi questo non i
maya normale all'inizio del processo
dopo di te e dove l'hanno portato che
non c'è più c'è ancora si trovava lì
però si è raffreddata così tanto che è
praticamente in equilibrio termico con
l'ambiente alla stessa temperatura
dell'ambiente che in questo caso è
l'aver integrare ma si può anche
scendere più in basso ovviamente perché
questo ci potrebbe servire per un
viaggio spaziale però la domanda non è
banale dalla su marte ci vogliono circa
nove mesi più o meno nelle condizioni
ideali se vendono astronave astronave
diciamo che è previsto che abbia sei
membri dell'equipaggio chiuso in una
scatolina cabina telefonica volante
questi sei membri di equipaggio
mangeranno per il viaggio d'andata di
riforme per il periodo che fanno su
marte e spedire qualcosa nello spazio
costa un sacco di soldi
si stima che il costo totale effettivo
sia quasi 60mila euro al chilo quando
andate da solo miele comprare il cibo
non lamentatevi se il prezzo non è di
questo tipo di fronte a questa spesa ci
sono anche altri problemi per esempio
nel simulazione fatte a terra molte
persone vanno incontro a una crisi
psicotica anno quello che si chiama
cabin fever in inglese alla fantascienza
aveva già previsto tutto
e inoltre ci sono delle radiazioni molto
pericolose nello spazio perché i fasci
di protoni e gli ioni pesanti che sono
molto pericolose stessi si esposti per
molto tempo risolvere questi problemi
non è facile ma la cosa bellissima
sarebbe che sono effettivamente
potessimo ibernare l'equipaggio
l'equipaggio non devi più mangiare
problema del cibo risolto non può più
avere attacchi psicotici non è cosciente
problema risolto e per di più come se la
fortuna non ci avesse aiutato abbastanza
l'ibernazione conferisce l'importante
protezione dalle radiazioni
quindi sarebbe la condizione migliore
per il viaggio nello spazio e non solo
per andare su marte che tutto sommato
relativamente vicino ma già qualcuno
inizia a pensare ad andare qui su questo
piccolo pianeta che non è un pianeta ma
un satellite che è europa che gira
nell'orbita di giove molto più lontano
di nove mesi di viaggio che si
aspetterebbero per andare su marte
detto questo qualcuno di voi potrebbe ma
quanto costa a fare queste cose perché
dobbiamo spendere queste cose per
progetti chissà dove ci porteranno beh
ve lo dico io quanto costa cioè non
quanto costa questo ma quanto costa la
scienza quanto costa questo questo tipo
di approccio questo il costo del
progetto genoma umano un costo tutto
sommato importante che è accompagnato da
costi rilevanti di altri progetti
scientifici per esempio human brain
project lhc che ha scoperto il bottone
del bosone di higgs
ma quanto costano le cose della nostra
vita di tutti i giorni
per questo è quanto costato fare avatar
il film con un solo film avete
finanziato un progetto di scienza di
rivoluzionario quanto deve la gente
secondo voi alcolici negli stati uniti
in un anno deve così facciate fare una
piccola tassazione di questo potrebbe
finanziare altro gli enormi progetti ma
ci sono anche cose ancora più costose
quanto costa a progettare e sviluppare
gli f35 per dire un caccia militare
quindi la scienza non costa tanto il
console senza veramente modesto rispetto
soprattutto al vantaggio che può portare
e perché possa portare questo vantaggio
bisogna che la scienza abbia una
caratteristica che accompagni gli
scienziati che ci lavorano la scienza
deve essere libera libera devono essere
le persone che ci lavorano in questo
cielo che abbiamo visto in tutte queste
slide adesso non abbiamo ancora visto
non l'ha visto nessuno di noi perché
questo non è il cielo della terra questo
è il cielo visto da marte e questa
pallino qui è la terra è qua si vede
anche la luna addirittura allora perché
noi possiamo arrivare un giorno
effettivamente a vedere questo cielo
bisogna che ricerche come quella
dell'ibernazione che è partita da
curiosità scientifiche nessuno aveva
pensato questa applicazione all'inizio
quella che si chiama ricerca di base e
nasce proprio dalla libertà dello
scienziato nel cercare nel perseguire
quello colui che ce ne siano
interessanti
bisogna che la nostra libertà di ricerca
sia supportata ed appoggiata se vogliamo
alla fine aiutare e supportare la
scienza io vi ringrazio siete state un
pubblico bellissimo